in the previous video splitting this
3-pack of soap with my wife she cut it
right down the middle so we each got
half of all three bars or we got three
halves or we got three halfs each bars
or each of us got three halfs bars of
soap now just to make sure that we
really understand what three halves is
and remember three halves is really the
same thing as 3/2 if someone says 3/2
you could say hey I'm gonna represent
that as three halves or someone says
three halves they could say you could
say well that's the same thing as 3/2
3/2 but just to really understand this
number let's actually think about where
we would plot it on a number line as
well so let me draw a number line here
I'm gonna start that as zero let me draw
a line so a straighter line as I am
capable of drawing and let's say that
this right over here represents one so
that would be one bar of soap in this
example and let's say that this right
over here is half a bar this is half a
bar and let's say that this is at one
and a half one and a half bars and let's
say that this right over here is two
bars of soap so we have three halves so
let's think about this remember 3 is
just 3 3 halves it's 3 times 1/2 or
since we already split this into halves
we just have to go 3 of these halves so
let's do that so this is 1/2 this is 1/2
now we're gonna have two halves two
halves that takes us to 1 and we know
that because two halves is equal to 1
and now let's do our third half our
third half is right over here and so
that is three halves and we see three
halves is the exact same thing as one
and a half and just to hit that point
home we already saw the 3 divided 3
halves is the same thing as 3 divided by
2 if you were to divide 3 by 2 you would
get you would get well 2 goes into 3
exactly one time one time and then what
would you have left over well you would
have one
half leftover you would have one half
leftover so three halves is the same
thing as one and a half which is exactly
what we saw here you could view this as
we have one and a half bars of soap and
when this is where you would plot it on
the number line three halves is halfway
in between one and two